let me tell you about my favorite hair
care ingredient amodimethicone amy
dimethicone is a silicone and you might
have heard that silicones are heavy and
weigh down your hair but amy dimethicone
is different it has a positive charge in
its structure and in size like charges
repel so when there's enough ammo
dimethicone on your hair it gets a
positive charge and any extra image
dimethicone can't attach so you can only
get a thin film it's especially good for
damaged hair damaged sections of hair
have more of a negative charge so any
dimethicone sticks more to damaged hair
which is where you need more
conditioning after it sticks to your
hair it also connects to other ammo
dimethico molecules so you end up with a
protective shield in your hair that
lasts through several washes your hair
stays silky and doesn't turn into straw
on the day after you wash it imo
dimethicone works really well for a lot
of people who normally don't like
silicones in their hair my super
bleached hair gets weighed down by a lot
of silicone conditioners but this makes
it feel like it's never even been near
bleach